like where do you start first thing is
you start learning I nowadays love
reading biographies of people of
successful I mean not just entrepreneurs
but really all kinds of people you hear
their story and their Journeys it's not
just motivational but very educational
indirectly because you get to hear what
they did from their own opinions so it's
like you know what would you pay to have
lunch with Warren Buffett well it
doesn't matter what you pay it's not
worth his time so now you start learning
the second thing I start doing and so if
you have a job do it in addition to that
don't just quit your job unless you have
the financial resources to fall back on
it's going to be hard because you're
going to say well I'm already working so
much and I got kids and I know it's hard
when there's a will there's a way and
this is so true with every aspect of Our
Lives if you really want to make a
change you will find a way to do it
you'll wake up an hour earlier you'll go
to bed an hour later you will find some
time on the weekends you'll find
sometimes in the middle of your work day
to do something just remember it gives
you energy your purpose gives you energy
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
thank you so much for stopping by uh
today is special because for the first
time I'm interviewing somebody about
money
now money is something that I don't
worry a lot about I'm super blessed I've
had a really successful career but I
also don't understand it that well and
so today's interview is with jaspreet
Singh he is an entrepreneur I invest
tons in companies and in himself he's an
attorney
and he also is a financial educator he
has an incredible YouTube channel called
minority mindset the beginning of the
conversation was all about mindset
because
I'm sure that you all want to hear like
what do I invest in what do I do here
what do I do there like tell me the nuts
and bolts and we get to that stuff but
at the end of the day if you don't have
the right mindset about money it's the
Rich Dad Poor Dad syndrome you're gonna
always be poor if you don't have the
right idea of why you're doing it
purpose finding something that you're
passionate about it just honestly
doesn't really matter and it's not going
to stick so there's definitely a chunk
at the beginning that I think is
actually the most important thing when
it comes to money then we got into it we
got into all kinds of really fun topics
about you know what to invest in we
talked about crypto a little bit at the
end he has a great answer for like if
you had to invest five thousand dollars
what should you invest in and you gotta
listen to the end to hear it I've never
talked to anybody about money and
finances before really yes I'm the first
one I feel special yeah and you know
there's a couple reasons one is I'm very
fortunate like I'm not in a position
that I worry about it
um you know I had a success successful
career
um but also like I interestingly grew up
with a dad that had a really like a
really positive association with money
we didn't worry about it we were he
spoiled us as kids we didn't turn out
like completely rotten
um and so like I really just wonder how
much of that mindset is what got me into
a position where money wasn't a problem
like it's sort of the chicken or the egg
that I'm really curious about and why
this isn't an area that I have really
delved into
um math is also not my strong suit I 100
agree that your mindset is what
determines your financial success
more than anything else
um it doesn't matter how much money you
make where you come from what your
background is if you don't have the
right mindset about money you will be
broke and you're gonna say just breed
what are you talking about uh well just
look at the numbers 78 of lottery
winners end up broke or bankrupt within
the first few years of them winning the
lottery you have about eight out of 10
NFL players who end up broke or bankrupt
a few years out of them leaving the
league you have so many NBA players that
end up broker bankrupt after finishing
the time at the NBA why it's not that
they were making money they were making
millions well it's that mindset about
money what do you do with money and this
is where now you have to understand okay
if it's not how much money I have or how
much money I earn it's what I do with
the money I make that has to be now
mindset related this is what I talk
about regarding Financial education now
this doesn't mean that how much money
you make doesn't make doesn't matter
because it does once you have the right
Financial education earning more money
has the most impact because now you know
what to actually do with your money you
know where to put your money you know
how to spend your money you know how to
invest your money but if you don't have
that basic Financial education which
unfortunately most of us myself included
are never taught it is going to become
extremely difficult and nearly
impossible because you don't know what
to do with the money we live in this
consumerism culture it's the reality
okay hate her to love it we live in this
culture where it's all about the
Instagram Flex what nice stuff can I
have what can I show off on Instagram
what does my friend post on Instagram do
I have nice stuff like them and this is
the system that we're in and it's good
if you understand the system because now
you can be a producer in this system
it's bad if you don't understand the
system because now you're the one being
screwed over by by the system okay so
what I'm trying to get at is
instead of trying to fight the system
learn the system that way you can use it
to your advantage this is what Financial
education is all about because this is
how it works it's like gravity okay it's
around us it is there it is happening it
has been happening and it's going to
continue to happen even after you're
gone you might as well learn it that way
you can make the best situation for
yourself for your family and your
community because you know I grew up
being told
don't worry about money don't talk about
money money is bad money is evil and it
rots people this is the the mindset that
I grew up with my parents are immigrants
I'm a state in India called Punjab they
came to this country with very little my
dad had less than a hundred dollars when
he came to America he didn't speak
English he didn't know the culture he
didn't know people he didn't he didn't I
mean he came to this country not knowing
what to expect it was his first time
here and he just moved here uh trying to
have a better life because
life was very different in Punjab
especially then so my they grew up very
poor my grandparents were refugees uh
they got kicked out of their homes when
they were teenagers they my grandfather
literally slept on the streets because
he had no home
um because there was like riots looting
all this stuff happening he had a fight
for his life literally and then even
when my dad was growing up in Punjab
in the 80s this is actually just a
couple days ago he was telling me the
story where
before he learned to drive he was he
just finished College this is 1984. he
came home uh the day after uh graduating
School in India he comes home and uh
these attacks start on her home state of
Punjab and he's talking about how people
left and right are being killed how they
would the men would sleep outside the
woman would sleep inside to protect the
home and you know he's seeing bombs and
shells going off over his home so after
that he's like you know let me leave
comes to America but next to nothing for
the idea of a better life because yeah
are things perfect in America no but you
know you don't got to worry about a bomb
dropping over your head so it's a pretty
nice and so he comes here
and with that mindset of I'm gonna do
whatever it takes to succeed
and with that type of immigrant mindset
you want your kids to become successful
yeah and what does that translate to
well for my parents like many other
immigrant parents it's your kids should
become a doctor why a doctor because
when you're a doctor it comes with a lot
of prestige uh it comes with the status
and it comes with a big salary and
safety and so you assume that if you're
a doctor you're at the top of the food
chain everything is going to be fine
you're going to live a great life and
you're not going to have to worry about
things like money like your parents did
and so that's the whole mindset and
that's what I was told don't worry about
all these things don't worry about
investing and all this other stuff that
my parents had no idea about instead
just go and become a doctor because now
you're going to be great and
everything's gonna be just fine
well
along the way I realized
that there's a lot more to life than
becoming a doctor there's a lot more to
money than just earning a big salary and
that was the turning point for me to
become financially educated because
unfortunately
many people
follow a career just for the money many
people become doctors just for the money
I almost became one of those people
um now don't get me wrong I love helping
people it is a part of my culture and
it's a part of me I I love helping
people it is something that morally I
want to do now medicine is you're
helping people but you're also getting
paid for it right it's not community
service by being a doctor like you were
doing it for payment right so exactly I
want to help as many people as I can as
a doctor this is where my my brain
string started to get pulled upon I want
to help people as a doctor but I also
want to maximize my Revenue because I'm
starting to think financially well what
does that mean does that mean that I'm
going to have to maximize my patience
perhaps sacrifice the quality of work
that I do but morally that doesn't seem
right so I'm starting to face this like
big war internally where maybe I'm not
doing this for the right reasons and
that's also kind of when I fell upon
Financial education and investing in
entrepreneurship and I realized wow
there's so many other ways to earn and
there's so many other ways for me to
give and I realize that yeah I like
medicine I like the whole idea of being
a doctor and helping people but I was
wondering for the wrong reasons like I
have so much more love for
entrepreneurship like if I became a
doctor
I would go to work and come back and and
that's it like I would do it because I
like it and I get paid but for me
talking about entrepreneurship this is
all I do like I eat sleep and breathe my
businesses that I run I love what I do
like I wouldn't want to do anything else
I go on a vacation my wife knows
I can't go on a vacation without us
working when we went on a honeymoon
she's like okay can you please not work
more than like four hours a day please
and so you know we had to make these
compromise it's not because like
I feel compelled to but because I
actually enjoy this and I see the impact
and I see the purpose and it just it's
like if I don't work I feel unfulfilled
and so it's that difference and it all
starts with the mindset of how do we
look at money how does money play an
aspect in our lives and how do we want
money to flow in our lives yeah and this
is this is all regarding you know it
starts with that mindset so I know this
is a really long drawn out answer to
your question great I have so many
questions to follow up and oddly enough
this is kind of where I was going to get
to at the end but I'm glad we started
here because I really think
foundationally this is such a pivotal
point this is like what you build your
financial education intelligence and
standpoint from is like what's your
mindset and then what's your lifestyle
so what I'm hearing is that
you love what you do so much and you've
clearly had so much traction and success
as a result so it do you do you get
energy from doing what you do
yes
and what's funny is I think people see
me as successful because of the brand
that I built on YouTube uh what's called
minority mindset and what's funny is
when I started minority mindset I had no
intention of making money
I was doing it as a hobby because I was
working on a different company at the
time which was my real time commitment
and my like
I don't want to say purpose but that's
where my energy was going I was running
a sock company that I created
and during the launch I got screwed over
I got scammed by a fake marketing
company that took a few thousand dollars
damn and I got upset
um but you know I think when someone has
an entrepreneurial bug you're like okay
I'm upset let me go to the gym now what
do I do and for me that was it was like
okay you know either I'm gonna sit here
and cry about it or you know let me do
something because entrepreneurship is
one of those things that I had to do it
in secret because if my parents found
out that I was running you know
businesses they were not going to be
happy because they had nothing to do
with me becoming a doctor my true story
so I ran all of my early businesses from
high school through college in secret
and
when I launched the saw company I got
screwed over and I was like it's just
frustrated because I had no support I
never had a mentor I never knew kind of
where to go I would always get my
education from books and I hated reading
books uh until I started reading
business books so that was when I was
like you know
let me try to create something to help
other people like me so I put out a
class on this platform called udemy on
how to launch a business without getting
screwed over I put it out for like seven
bucks I don't really care about making
money it was just a way for me to like
put out some education to help people
who were in a similar situation because
I got screwed over so the class did
really well and I did it under the Alias
minority mindset just because I thought
that I thought differently than the
majority of people that's awesome and
yeah and the classic well and people
were like oh my God this is so cool can
you create a social media page
I was like sure so I created an
Instagram page called minority mindset
where I essentially did the same thing I
made posts on like just basic things
that I wish I knew about you know
business and money management and stuff
like that and I was making these posts
on Instagram and people would send me
DMS and comments saying would you mind
starting a blog because like this is
really long and it's hard to read on
Instagram like just to start a blog and
I was like you don't want me to start a
blog like English is my second language
is you're not gonna enjoy that so no but
I don't mind talking so I'll make
YouTube videos so I started making
videos on YouTube under the same Alias
minority mindset while I was running
this company and I was in law school at
the time so you know I was fully
committed to a lot of other things
um and I start making these videos
it's not a doctor but law school yeah
well the reason why I went to law school
is because when I told my parents I'm
not going into medicine they were like
you have to at least become an attorney
to maintain any pride in the family so
uh but I love them okay this was like
this is a different situation they were
they were doing it out of love they
didn't have the financial education
so that was when around ten thousand or
fifteen thousand or so subscribers this
is before YouTube had any sort of
monetization requirements like anybody
could monetize any Channel with any
views my friend asked me how much money
are you making on YouTube like what are
you talking about man it's like you know
like from your ads on YouTube I'm like
I'm not making any money he's like what
are you talking about so he goes into my
YouTube back end with me and he's like
dude you haven't even turned on
advertisements on your videos like you
can just push this button and you'll
start generating revenue from your
videos and I was like oh like like
that's how much like I was just doing it
because I enjoyed it uh not because like
I I needed to make money I was doing it
for completely different reasons
and then slowly minority Minds have
started to grow and I made the decision
to shut down my other company and focus
on minority mindset not because I was
making more money but because I enjoyed
it way more and
um yeah so the minority Master kept
growing and then that helped Spur off a
number of other business that I am now
running uh while doing the videos so
it's like a kind of an interesting story
where like what you were saying where
when you do your passion and then kind
of for me I led with value and the money
came kind of followed and that's why
here at the minority mindset companies
our core one of our core values is lead
with value always just provide value and
then uh focus on that and the money will
follow it's so so so true so true
um I had very similar views along the
way where I was like you know I would
turn down money because it wasn't the
right branding or I would turn certain
things down or opportunities I'm like
look if I'm good at what I do they'll
always want me and exactly I share I
share that with you but I I kind of want
to distill this down to like a nugget
for people because what I've found is
that the things that are really that are
your purpose and calling and that you'll
do really well are the things that give
you energy versus take energy so and it
has nothing to do with the amount of
work it takes in fact it has nothing it
just has nothing to do with that I could
go do an hour autograph session at a you
know somewhere who knows who cares and
it's just kind of shallow hellos and
goodbyes and signing things and I would
be so drained it's under artificial
light there's no windows I would just um
it was like you unplugged me and then I
could sit here and do six hours of
podcasts where
you know I have to think and I have to
plan and I'm I'm like navigating these
conversations with people and I would
get done with the that many hours and I
would feel almost high like a buzz like
like energy so much energy so I I just
think that it's a really good little
nugget for people to know that it's the
things that you love and that fuel you
and that you that you do as your side
hustle like you kind of did that they
talk about so much in the business World
a side hustle that's your real purpose
and that's a good navigation tool to
know like what you should and shouldn't
do exactly and you know we kind of have
a running joke here in our office here
uh because I don't drink coffee
um I I drink tea and my team here has
like a running joke that if I had coffee
like I would just go off the walls
berserk they keep the coffee away from
me do they think you double your output
I I did I think that they got double my
output and that required double from
them as well so yeah like keep the
coffee away what is money that's like I
have these fantasies about living
um Off the Grid and exchanging services
for for life like what is why couldn't
that be possible yeah and so what's
money that's a great question well
what's its purpose yeah where did it
come from that's a multi-part question
so let's let's go like maybe a little
bit philosophical to a little bit more
technical cool so philosophically money
is freedom we don't care about having
dollars we don't care about having cash
like that doesn't do anything for us
like if you had 10 million dollars of
cash but the cash no one is there to buy
it and you can't buy anything with it it
doesn't do anything it's just a piece of
paper that's taking up space so they
don't technically want that cash we want
what money can buy which for many of us
is freedom uh sure maybe you might think
oh but I want a Lambo I want this I want
that yeah I mean those things can be
nice and money can buy you that too but
for most people we want freedom we want
the freedom to be able to live our lives
the way we want we want the freedom to
wake up when we want we want the freedom
to work on the things that we want we
want the freedom to buy our spouse the
things that they want we want the
freedom to send our kids to school where
they want we want the freedom to go to
the best doctors that we can we want the
freedom to eat where we want and we want
the freedom to go on vacation wherever
we want it's the freedom that money can
buy that most of us are after
now if we go a little bit deeper into
what is money technically
this is where money can get a little bit
confusing and this goes into a lot of
kind of economic Concepts that most of
the times we're never taught and this
goes into now what is money because
money can either be a means of exchange
or it can be a store of value so I'm
gonna try not to get too Technical and
too confusing but what that means is
if you had ten thousand dollars with the
cash and you dug this into your backyard
today in 10 years or 20 years is that
ten thousand dollars gonna buy you the
same same stuff that they can buy you
today
and the answer is no
now why well the quest the answer is
because our money what we think of as
money on paper dollars isn't the best
store of value our money what we call
Money loses value every single day
because of something called inflation so
what we call money isn't the best dollar
value but it's a good currency meaning
means of exchange if you have ten
thousand dollars in your hand you can go
to the Apple Store buy a nice MacBook
you can buy a laptop you can buy you
know whatever you want to buy because
you have that money to do that so this
is where old money we'll call it old
money things like physical gold your
traditional money
serves a better store of value because
it takes time effort and labor to mine
an ounce of gold
and that representation of that time
effort and labor is through the physical
gold so the physical gold serves as a
better store of value but it's not a
very good means of exchange because now
if you go to Lululemon or you go to
Apple or you go to Gucci and you walk in
with a gold bar and you say can I buy
this they're going to look at you really
confused because they don't know what to
do with that maybe somebody will take it
because they're they're a little bit
financially educated and they'll say oh
yeah I'll take this but most people are
going to say no and so this is where you
have to understand the difference
between the currency means of exchange
and store value let me ask one little
question just as a technicality so are
you saying that it's the time and effort
it takes to get the gold that is the
value or is it the gold itself
it is the gold so the value so if you
talk about value versus price uh the
price of anything at the end of the day
is determined by supply and demand so it
might cost you a hundred thousand
dollars to build a home but the home
might be worth 50 000 or it might be
worth a million dollars depending on
where it is and so kind of like that
that's where physical gold also has a
difference in the cost to mine it but
then it also has some sort of store of
value just like how a house has some
store value because it has bricks it has
Windows it has flooring it has all these
things that have the value it provides
shelter and so it has that kind of Basic
Value but then the price ultimately is
determined by now market conditions
supply and demand you know when you're
in a recession home prices go down when
interest rates change home prices uh get
affected so there's there's that
differentiation that you need to
understand as well uh when you
differentiate value versus price okay
move one step back from the technical
side and remove back to a little bit of
the philosophical philosophical kind of
in the middle how does money play a part
in our lives and this was a challenge
that I had to really learn
the hard way because you know I grew up
being told when he's bad when he's evil
don't worry about it just go become a
doctor the reason why so many people
create these smoke screens around money
these this taboo culture around money is
because we don't understand how money
plays a part in our lives we think that
more money
is either going to make us evil or you
know we say more money is not going to
make you happy and that's correct to an
extent because I have created this thing
what I call the quadrified theory and
the way it works is we have four aspects
to our life and if you want to live a
happy and fulfilled life you have to be
fit in these four aspects okay and the
Order of them is at the bottom physical
fitness then mental Fitness and
spiritual Fitness and then at the top
you have Financial Fitness so if we go
back to the bottom with physical fitness
if you are on your deathbed you don't
care if you have 10 million dollars or
that you want us to be healthy again
because once you're healthy you can have
a thousand and one dreams wishes and
desires like you can actually go and do
things like I know you've talked about
your health Journey on your uh podcast
you've talked about that with great
guests your diet your your exercise your
body because if you are physically not
here it doesn't matter yeah so are you
saying that's number one or number four
number one so the bottom that's the most
important thing got it foundationally
foundationally then you have the mental
Fitness because now once you're
physically here yeah now you can start
thinking about your mind because if
you're miserable if you're anxious if
you're depressed if you're unhappy more
money is going to make you more
miserable and this is where now you have
to understand that your mental health is
its own aspect of life you have to take
care of that now this could mean talking
to therapists getting the right you know
help getting a life coach doing therapy
whatever that might be but you need to
take care of your mental health surround
yourself with people that you love
surround yourself with happiness
surround yourself with good energy not
toxic people get that stuff out because
if you are miserable
more money will not fix that like one
thing that I always talk about because I
have seen this firsthand with friends of
mine and I'm sure many people have where
I know people who are unhappy or were
unhappy and kept talking about man I
just want to make a million dollars
because once I'm making a million
dollars then you know this girl is going
to like me or this is going to happen
people are gonna you know want to be my
friend and it's like my whole life will
change because I have more money but
that is one of the biggest lies you can
tell yourself and you are going to
become even more miserable if you
achieve that financial success because
now you're going to feel even more empty
you're going to see that hey I got my
money but nobody likes me nobody wants
to be around me and so this is where you
have to solve that mental aspect of your
life
then is the spiritual aspect and this
isn't religious this is more of your
purpose why are you here on your Earth
and you were talking about the things
that make you feel fulfilled the things
that make you feel happy the things that
give you energy every single one of us
have these type of things yeah you just
gotta figure out what it is some of them
might help you make money which is great
some of them might not but at the end of
the day we're all here for a reason and
you want to be able to fulfill that
because if you don't and you become
financially successful you're going to
have no reason to get out of bed now
what do you do and so this is where you
want to be spiritually fulfilled have a
reason have your purpose and you know if
you don't know what this is that's okay
this is where you want to be learning so
it's understanding you know you have to
be physically fit mentally fit
spiritually fit all three of these
things have their own educations like
you go to YouTube go to podcasts we have
a bunch of content on this you know just
go and learn
from people that are talking about it
maybe you'll read a book maybe take a
class whatever it is but start learning
about that once you have these three
things this is where Financial Fitness
has the biggest impact and the most
value and the most power because now you
can live a more fulfilled life because
now the money is just like adding fuel
to the fires you can do more of the
things that make you feel more fulfilled
you can be around your friends and
family and go to fun places cool places
you can have the best diet you can have
you know all the nice things you can
hire a trainer but you have to have that
you know reason the mental aspect of
wanting these things and achieving these
things that way money can actually buy
you the things that will make you happy
and this is where you know understanding
how money plays a part in our life is so
important but then also understanding
the lack of money can impact every
single one of these things because now
if you don't understand money and if you
don't have money and if you don't have
any sort of financial education and
you're constantly stressing about money
you're constantly worried about money
you don't know how to pay your bills now
you can start eating bad and you can
affect your physical health it can
affect your mental health Financial
issues are one of the leading causes of
suicide that's one of the leading causes
of divorce it's it can cause a lot of
financial constraints a lot of mental
constraints
and it can also make you feel really
unfulfilled if you feel like you don't
have enough money so it's understanding
how money plays a part in our life but
then also understanding how money or the
lack of money plays a part in our life
if you do solve those bottom three
levels of the Pyramid of hierarchy of
being free and being happy is that
you know you got to start to think about
like what you really need to be happy I
think that's also a big question is what
what does it take to be happy and
reverse engineer your life
and anchor that future too because if
you feel like I need a yacht and a jet
and I want to go on lavish vacations
great now you know what you have to do
because you reverse engineer it but in a
lot of cases people go
man I want a decent car and a decent
house and good friends and I want time
with them and I want to be able to
travel a little bit but you know really
I just want to be able to go take my
dogs for a walk and have great dinners
and you know buy nice healthy food and
and then you all of a sudden now like it
almost like unlocks freedom because you
go okay I don't actually have to make
that million and then there's that
energetic release of like that wanting
because I listen to a lot of mindset
stuff and you know when you want
something so badly that grip is so it
strangles the opportunity because
there's an equal and opposite belief
that you don't have it like if you want
something so badly it implies that you
don't have it I think that can play a
big role so like the why explain your
whys and what kind of got you on to
a path where you felt really comfortable
you felt like you felt confident in your
position with your family
um you know what what was it that got
you over that hump and then also yes
answer that question first sure so it's
interesting you brought that up because
I talked about this with um a guy named
Tom bilyu impact Theory just recently
yeah and he asked me a similar question
and he really helped me understand this
a little bit better because I kind of
went through an interesting Journey on
this same thing
where initially
for me was to prove everybody wrong
because when I knew I wanted to be an
entrepreneur like I started off when I
was in elementary school I was mowing my
neighbor's Lawns because I wanted to
make some extra money to take care of my
parents because I saw how hard they were
working and my parents were like no
don't do that just focus on your studies
so I was like okay fine then as I went
to high school I started doing more I
started playing a drum at Indian
weddings uh turned some extra cash and
again I did this in secret because I
didn't want my parents to find out
because I knew they kind of had a hint
and every time they found out that I was
doing this type of stuff they were very
angry so I always did it in secret
and so for me initially it was to take
care of my parents but also to show that
hey you can be successful as an
entrepreneur because there was a lot of
conversations that I had with my family
not just my parents but extended family
of people saying how can someone like
you be a CEO of a company like how like
because I openly said I want to be a CEO
one day and they were like how can
someone like you who has no business
experience someone with your background
be the CEO of a company one day and I
remember that and that that kind of left
me a little Scar and so I was like you
know what I'm gonna do it in silence and
then as like it became more and more
known over the years that I'm doing this
entrepreneurial stuff
it was a very interesting kind of
response because at first when my
parents found out that I was an
entrepreneur by accident so I was
running the stock company and
um we ended up getting some coverage on
the news because our company was doing
really well one of my parents friends
saw it and they called up my parents and
they said we saw your son on the news
and so my parents were like what did he
do now like they were just like what
happened they're like no no no he has a
successful company he's like got these
sales and they were like what and so
when they heard that that was when they
kind of changed their mindset they're
like okay clearly John Philip is not
going to listen to us and he's doing
okay so that was when they started
changing their mindset about okay you
know what do what you want but then like
culturally
um people kind of use that as a way to
pick fun because like I would go to
these events and uh I would have these
like random people come up to me say oh
so uh how is your sock business going
like how is selling socks on the
internet because it was like you know
you were supposed to be a doctor now
you're selling stocks online which is
kind of funny
um but I always knew I was like you know
you don't get it like you don't know
what I know what you don't see what I
see like my like and they were just kind
of
it was like in a weird that it was like
I never said anything but I just kind of
internalized it where you know what this
is my motivation I want to prove
everybody wrong so it's kind of like
this dark energy
um in the beginning where it's like you
know what I'm doing this out of spite
I'm gonna prove every single person
wrong every single person that doubted
me I am gonna make you eat your words
you know after a certain point
it started to change for me where it's
like wow
I'm making an impact
I'm helping people I love that idea I
start to see how
this education the financial education
is so important and I want to help
spread this word I want to help provide
this value to the world there's so many
changes that I want to make and so it
started to shift slowly over to this
kind of like more positive energy more
light energy as opposed to just the dark
energy so it started off with this like
intense desire to I'm going to prove you
wrong I'm not going to sleep I'm gonna
wake up early I'm gonna do whatever I
can to prove every single person without
any belonged to now
I'm doing this because I I see the
impact of this and I want to make a
difference so kind of a shift in that
sense so if you wanted to prove them
wrong you know essentially like you did
there's a ceiling to that right there's
like an end point and I don't know maybe
you can share your thoughts I think the
most some of the most powerful goals are
the ones that don't have a ceiling yeah
right if you want to make a difference
that doesn't end right and so people set
these goals to it's great to have your
sort of intermittent goals along the way
they're sort of markers in time they
allow you to celebrate along the way but
but the ultimate Manifesto sort of like
whatever the statement is about what it
is that you're doing whatever your brand
mission is or your mission in general
I don't know maybe you could share your
thoughts around that being something
that doesn't have a ceiling and
therefore can take
the most expansive form possible
yeah I think you're right it's it's
something that it becomes more of a
purpose of for you and your mission of
really just as a human because I mean if
you look at some of the wealthiest
people in the world you look at Warren
Buffett why does he still get up and
work like
like you have all the money in the world
you're I mean you could literally just
fly around in a private jet and just do
the most exotic things in the world wow
all day every day all day every day and
never have to stress about money ever
well he likes what he does he likes
researching companies he is he gets a
certain excitement out of that that you
don't get out of doing other things and
so for him it's it's that matter of
purpose and you look at like you know an
easy example to see is just look at
shark tank you have these sharks on
Shark Tank why are they there they don't
need more money right they enjoy
entrepreneurship they got to where they
were because they were entrepreneurs
that entrepreneurial energy is something
that you want to be around and so now
you can help other entrepreneurs and go
back into the entrepreneurial energy
another million dollars when you have
100 million dollars doesn't change your
life it doesn't really affect you at all
it's just one of those things where
it's for the purpose the energy and the
fun and the excitement and the impact
that you can make and I really think
you're right where
it's that no more ceiling it's it's it's
now how you have fun I mean this is like
exciting like my accountant calls me up
one day he says Just Breathe how are you
I said I'm good how are you who says uh
hey look I need you to do me a quick
favor uh can you send in a hundred
thousand dollars to the IRS by the end
of the day today oh also another 15 000
to the state government I was like what
because yes we missed some calculations
but you need to do that by the end of
the day today
I was like what are you talking about
and then he's like oh by the way you're
probably gonna have to pay penalty on
this as well
and so naturally I was a little um
upset and I was like he just threw me so
off guard and so I paid it and then I
fired my accountant and then I went on a
hunt for a new accountant naturally and
uh I found somebody after a lot of
research who was amazing like I was like
wow like I did not realize like there's
this level of like service in accounting
because I have experienced bad
accounting and you start to experience
like oh my God this is such a better
service and I worked with them for a
number of months like almost a year and
I was like you know
this is a great offer that you have like
what you're doing is great you don't
have any Internet presence let's work
together because I was like you know
there's a lot of small businesses out
there that need
your type of like service concierge and
care because there's a lot of people who
have accountants that all they do is
file your taxes which is not what an
accountant should be doing they should
be I mean there's a lot more that they
can be doing
and so you know why am I starting this
again it's it's yeah there's a value
there's Financial upside but it's also
fun like it's I love the energy of like
him and I brainstorming coming up with
ideas oh let's do this let's do this
having business meetings we were just uh
on a call yesterday with a very large uh
company that deals with a lot of tech
startups and does all the stuff and it
was like it's just a different type of
energy and fun that you get trying to
build and you know some people are going
to hate this stuff like you know another
person might say oh my God that sounds
like such a task and such a chore
I love it you know and it's It's All
Kinds of Kinds thank God everybody has
their own interests thank God exactly
and this is where you know Finding for
you what is that no ceiling what do you
enjoy doing what do you like creating
what do you like building and for me
it's it's I I like the entrepreneurial
side of things where it's just a lot of
fun for me yeah yeah a lot of fun when I
do it okay so let's go to some nuts and
bolts and some like takeaways some
because there's I would imagine most
anybody listening can sort of maybe they
have spent a few minutes here during
this conversation and intuitively
identified some things that they truly
enjoy doing and they're like man I
freaking hate my job and that's what
they realized in the last half hour
they're like I hate my job
um and that's I mean I think that's kind
of exciting so what happens now if
you're someone who knows what they love
maybe you're even someone who's got the
ball rolling a little bit and on the
side you're kind of playing around with
something else that you love how the
hell do you take that and
give it the right nourishment
to grow into something great like where
do you start so the first thing is going
to be so some of you have some sort of
idea first thing is you start learning
go on to YouTube start reading as many
books as possible uh so watch as many
business uh entrepreneurial
channels videos that can help you like
any books or I mean you have tons of
videos or on your YouTube but like any
books that were pivotal for you
uh well a lot of the pivotal books are
real are Financial books books related
to investing money management real
estate so I mean if you want to start
there you know Robert Kiyosaki has a
great book which had Poor Dad balance
that out with Dave Ramsey's books on uh
money management they're two completely
opposite uh opinions of money but
they're very very helpful books
um there's tons of books on anything
personal finance but now when you go to
the business side I nowadays love
reading biographies of people of
successful I mean not just entrepreneurs
but really all kinds of people you hear
their story and their Journeys it's not
just motivational but very educational
indirectly because you get to hear what
they did from their own opinions so it's
like you know what would you pay to have
lunch with Warren Buffett well it
doesn't matter what you pay it's not
worth his time uh but you know there's
books about things that he did same with
Richard Branson same with you know most
successful people so read books like
that or if you want more technical books
just go into Audible or Amazon and look
at the top 25 or 50 business books in a
category buy them all read them and
there is your MBA for less than I don't
know 200 bucks and I promise you you're
going to get more especially if you're
starting a business you're going to get
more value out of those books than you
will out of trying to go and do a
traditional MBA that's going to cost you
100 000 yeah no kidding okay so now you
start learning the second thing you
start doing and so if you have a job
do it in addition to that don't just
quit your job unless you have the
financial resources to fall back on it's
going to be hard because you're going to
say well I'm already working so much and
I got kids and I know it's hard but this
is where
when there's a will there's a way and
this is so true with every aspect of Our
Lives if you really want to make a
change you will find a way to do it
you'll wake up an hour earlier you'll go
to bed an hour later you will spend some
time on the weekends you'll find
sometimes in the middle of your work day
to do something just remember it gives
you energy your purpose gives you energy
exactly like you're gonna find a way and
uh you will and so I just start putting
it in an action and then when you screw
up tell yourself it's okay because
that's the part of the process if you're
not screwing up you're not trying enough
things like you have to make mistakes
you have to screw up but then when you
do screw up learn start again do it
again like I had to go from business
idea to business idea to business idea
to business idea like again and again
and again and again before I finally
found something that was sustainable for
me because
it was how I learned like I I screwed up
many times and some of the businesses
that I started did very well
and to stop them when you're like you
know you're making
six figures plus a year and then realize
this is not my passion this is not my
purpose I hate this industry and then
stop it
oh you feel like you're starting over
but this is one of those things where
you know
life is not a Sprint it's a marathon you
have time ahead of you and if you don't
do it now two years from now you're
gonna wish what if I just started two
years ago so might as well start now
take little steps and just keep inching
forward and then you'll see oh yeah even
though I screwed up so much I learned so
much I learned how to Market I learned
how to sell I learned how to build
something online and it's all a part of
the learning process and there's no
other way to do it besides just doing it
learning screwing up and doing it again
what about that that really interesting
point where you have put money into a
company
put money into a company that you want
it to be successful and you need to keep
investing money is there a certain point
in time is there any guidance
recommendation on that process being
like on advice on when you stop
investing like when it's foolish at some
point in time because in my experience
like my racing career was what it was
but in all these other companies that I
have it's like
God I just dumped money and it seems
like it takes money to make money and
I'm like okay we're kind of making
progress and then I'm like all right now
we need to scale a little bit we need
some more sales people we need to do
this now we need a tasting space in
Calistoga for your wine and now we need
this and you're like man at what point
in time do you like is there any any
recommendations on that process or even
just like give us a peace of mind of hey
you know what that's how it goes give
yourself five years give yourself ten
years give yourself freaking five
minutes and if you don't make money get
out like it's very I think it can be
very frustrating and I'm coming at it
from a place of Freedom Financial
Freedom but I'm also not stupid and I
don't do things to lose money so we're
we're where's the guidance in that so
Kevin O'Leary has talked about this
pretty openly I think he has a pretty
good uh rule of thumb what he says is if
you've been working on something for
three years and it's not making money
it's a hobby it's not a business so I
think that's a good place to start the
next thing that I would say is sometimes
too much money can be a disease because
you can just throw money at a problem
and assume that the money is just going
to fix or create whatever it is that you
want to do and I've been a victim of
that as well uh because you know we
always assume that oh I don't have a lot
of money to start this idea how am I
going to build it but sometimes that's
the best thing that can happen
um like my minority Minds the companies
this whole brand started off with less
than
I don't know 200 bucks because all I
started was making videos off my phone
and then I grew and grew and grew and
now we have a whole team we have
multiple companies under our belt but
one of the things that we tried to do
was build a Blog for minority mindset
the minoritymonster.com now I was
stretched very thin like I was doing so
many different things like I was
building Market briefs which is our
newsletter I was working on Market
insiders an app that we have I was
building my YouTube videos and I was
doing a lot of different things so for
me building this blog wasn't like my top
priority I had a team for it like we had
some staff members we had a ton of
freelance writers so we hired one of the
top
blog consultants in the world to manage
and lead and take charge of a Blog and
we were playing them paying them a lot
of money like over I don't remember how
much but over a hundred thousand dollars
a year like at least like on the low end
so a lot of money where you would expect
it okay just turn our blog around give
us some traction
so we paid them a lot of money
and we saw no growth I think actually
our website traffic went down and so now
if we're hundreds of thousands of
dollars in and now I was like exactly
like okay like yeah I'm okay financially
but this is just stupid like what is
happening here and so we fired the
agency we uh really Consolidated and
we're like okay
what do we need to do to turn this blog
around and so now it's like me investing
my time my energy and building a team to
start researching going back to the
basics researching learning
implementing failing and trying again
like fail fast is what they say so it
was one of those things where
you know we did it for a year and
realized this is definitely not the
right direction even though it takes a
long time to build a Blog and so we
completely turned it around now we have
a much smaller team but a faster growing
block and we're growing way faster than
we were before then when we had all that
money going into it so it's one of those
things where more money doesn't always
solve the problem it's going back to the
roots sometimes and being creative
that's what's exciting about being an
entrepreneur or a bootstrapper when
you're starting with nothing or very
little you got to figure it out like
when I was in college I was uh running
an event planning company
and I started this because in high
school I was hosting uh I started off
playing the drum Indian weddings
and then when I started working at
Indian weddings I got to meet a lot of
the local DJs the DJs had this idea for
us to host teen parties when I was in
high school
at this local restaurant that was
looking for more exposure because they
just opened so I did that for a little
while as a hobby
but I knew I was like you know this is
just for fun when I go to college I got
to really buckle down and become a
doctor
anyways I go to college not knowing what
to expect
and I see everybody around me partying
drinking doing all this stuff and I was
like well I don't drink I'm not really
into the party scene although I was
hosting the parties but I need something
to do on Friday nights so now I'm
knocking on the doors of every Club any
bar restaurant on campus trying to
figure out if I could host a party here
and I was 17 at the time
and one Club finally said yes you can
host a party here you don't have to pay
us anything just give us 50 of the
revenue that you generate the cover
charge I was like all right we're in
business because the previous places
that I talked to were asking for a
minimum of ten thousand dollars tell us
an event and I did not have anywhere
close to 10 grand so uh now we're in
business then I found a DJ
who was a friend of mine to work on a
commission basis that he would take 50
of the revenue that I generate so I'm
giving 50 to the club and then 25 to the
DJ which leaves 25 to me but I don't
have any costs it was a way for me to
get started and then now it was all
about being creative and clever with our
marketing uh like this is when Facebook
used to be very popular for younger
people like high schoolers and college
people and so Facebook would tell you
when everyone's birthday is and so we
would message everyone's birthday like
if it's the party was in September we'd
message everybody in September and say
hey because it's your birthday we want
to celebrate we're going to announce
your name at the club at the event and
we'll also give you free entry into the
party now free entry doesn't cost us
anything and shouting you out doesn't
cost you anything but nobody wants to
celebrate their birthday alone you're
going to bring your closest five to ten
friends and so you know it's just a
Creative Marketing of how can you now
get the word out without spending all
this money and just figuring it out
because many times we assume that the
reason why we can't become successful is
because we don't have the tool set when
in reality it's we're lacking the
mindset and so we have to work on that
mindset first and then you can build the
tool set after
great great advice
um creativity always is such a big
player in business I feel like
um you brought up kind of like this sort
of almost like partnership and so I
wonder from a business perspective as
companies grow
you know one of the questions that comes
along the way I feel like
you know obviously there's scaling of
this but having a partner having an
investor or what if a company gets so
big and then you're like we need Capital
we need to do a seed round to get
investors then you can kind of progress
from there at all the levels but
you know I've always been stuck
personally on wanting to own things a
hundred percent and just you know and
and I and I'm not I don't think that
that's the right mindset so I'm curious
on your advice about releasing some of
this control and where partners and
investors come into things
so this is a very very very good
question
um and something that I've definitely
struggled with
um I like control as well I think you
know part of being an entrepreneur is
you want to be the one in charge which
is why for all of our companies we
bootstrapped everything up till now we
haven't raised any money so I own like
for example the minority monster
companies I own all of it however as we
grew I did give a little percentage to
my parents kind of as like a gift here
this is just a way you have a good heart
you do
look when you go after because I invest
in companies like I am a investor I've
invested in a number of startups and
what happens is you know there's nothing
wrong with raising money but you have to
understand what that comes with because
now when you and open up the door to
let's just say venture capital or
investors
you almost have a boss and sometimes
when you're an entrepreneur you don't
want that like you want to have all
control you want to make the decisions
and that's fine and doesn't really just
have to understand you and know what
your goals are because as soon as you
open up the door to investors for
example now your investors are going to
ask you every quarter give us a
financial report we want to see the
remedy we want to see for sure the
profits and then they're going to start
giving you recommendations how about you
start doing this how about you start
doing this now depending on your
personality you're either going to love
it or you're gonna hate it and you have
to be honest with yourself because not
everybody can handle that and as soon as
you open up the door for Venture Capital
you can't slow down now it's all gas
forward because every investor is going
to want to see a return on their money
as fast as possible
which can be great
if that's your personality but it can
also drive you insane if that's not what
you want to deal with so that's the
issue or concern things you need to
think about when it comes to raising
money second on the aspect of a partner
if you want a partner that's fine uh
like in this new tax firm that I'm
starting I have a partner uh I'm an
attorney he is the financial like the he
has a tax firm and so he has all that
experience in accounting him and I are
partnering but we make a great balance
because we've both at a place
financially where we understand that hey
we're okay and we both understand both
of our roles
he is the one that's doing the actual
building assistance for the accounting
taking care of the clients and making
sure that all of our team is taking care
of the clients I'm on the operation side
I'm on the marketing side I'm on the
growth side because this is what I
understand he doesn't step toes where I
need to go and I'm going to let him do
his thing where he needs to be so it's a
good balance in that sense
can be for intelligence partners are for
diversification partners are for
divvying up the workload partners are to
expand the oh like potential because of
bringing in other brains that can do
other things exactly and so this is
where you know it's much easier for me
to do that because
I know I'm going to be okay no matter
what and I need him in order to build
this just like he would need me in order
to grow it to the scale that we want to
go I think initially you know having a
partner where you've given up the equity
you're giving up the profits you're
giving up to someone because you think
that they're not going to pull their end
of the weight I would say limit the
partners to
one other that you don't want five
Partners I have seen this in many
companies when you have five Partners or
multiple partners now you have so many
opinions you have so many hands in the
pot so many people that are trying to do
things and everybody gets emotional
everybody wants things done their own
way and you might think no this is
different it's not different I have seen
it so many times
where as soon as things start to go
wrong or as soon as money starts to come
in now that changes people because when
you when it comes to planning especially
the business you have to plan for the
worst case scenario and the best case
scenario
and the more people you have on the much
it becomes exponentially more difficult
so if you're going to have Partners
limit them and be very picky with who
you work with what are a couple of like
just top traits that you look for when
you're either hiring somebody or working
with somebody like what do you what do
you find to be a com some common
denominators with really successful
great people to be in business with
first is work ethic you have to be
willing to work hard
second is Passion because that's
something that you can't teach like work
ethic and passion you cannot teach it's
something that's just ingrained in a
person and by Passion
passion can solve a lot of problems when
you have the right work ethic because
now when you're really passionate about
doing something and you don't know how
to do it you're going to start learning
instead of saying
um oh how do I do this go to Google go
to YouTube you know it's just like all
these things when you're passionate
you're going to find a way and those are
the two biggest biggest drivers like
like here when we have interviews for an
employee
that's the first two things that we look
for it's your passion and work ethic
because if you don't have that it
doesn't matter what degree what skill
set what anything you have
you're not going to fit in well because
we are very demanding and we need you to
be able to learn very quickly and figure
things out and if you can't do that it's
very difficult to have a good partner
just because they're smarter to have a
lot of money they're not going to be
able to provide necessarily that value
unless that's all you want if you just
want someone's be able to phone them
fine if you just want their paycheck
that's fine but just know what you're
getting what about when we start to
think about building retirement or
building and you know building some
comfort and security financially for the
Long Haul is there like a certain amount
or certain amount that you set aside is
there a certain age that you okay from
now on this is where I really like start
putting things aside and I start
planning for retirement and freedom from
that perspective or even techniques I
mean retirement plans 401ks all that
stuff you know what what kind of things
do you do or what do you recommend for
people
so in terms of when you start the sooner
the better the earlier the better time
is the most beneficial and impactful
Factor when it comes to building
long-term wealth because like just to
put some numbers on it if you start when
you're 21 and you start investing just a
hundred dollars a month at 21 and you do
that every month until you're 66 years
old and you never increase how much
money you're investing just a hundred
dollars a month and you can get an
average return 10 a year on your 100 a
month investment this doesn't mean your
investment's got to go up by 10 every
year it's just an average return which
is the average stock market return
historically you're going to retire a
millionaire with 100 a month but if you
know you're in your 20s and you're just
trying to enjoy life in 30s you're
trying to figure out your career and
then your 40s are like all right you
know let's start thinking about
retirement because you know I still got
a lot of time but let me start thinking
about it and then you start putting
aside the same hundred dollars a month
and you get the same return
well if you start
in your 40s when you're 45
you're not going to have a million
dollars you're not going to have three
quarters of a million you're not even
going to have a half a million or one
quarter of a million you're going to
retire with one hundred thousand dollars
which is very far away from what you'll
need in order to be able to live a nice
retirement without worrying about money
so time has the most value now if you're
starting later does that mean it's
impossible for you no absolutely not it
just means you have to get a little bit
more serious and learn what to do
because at the end of the day what do
you need to do you need to spend more
you need to earn more than you spend and
then you need to put that money to work
you have to understand how involved you
want to be with your Investments you
know 401K Ira these are great places to
start but they should absolutely not be
your sole retirement plan even the
founder of the 401K has come out
publicly and he has said that the 401K
has gone awry that he's created a
monster because so many people are
looking at the 401K as their sole
retirement plan that I will have my 401k
Social Security and I'm good to go no
that is not the case that is where you
start that is not where you end so what
does that mean you have to be investing
your money yourself now this can be in
the stock market this can be in real
estate this can be you investing in
startups like there's there's an
unlimited number of places where you can
invest
but you have to do it it doesn't have to
be a lot of money to start there are so
many apps out there that let you start
investing with less than a hundred
dollars there's some apps that even
start letting you invest with one dollar
so there's no excuse in terms of
accessibility because anybody can put
aside one dollar
and you might think well what is one
dollar gonna do well it's just the start
I'm not saying invest one dollar never
think about it again just start and keep
contributing to it and keep growing that
and you I mean the easiest one of the
not easy but simplest thing to do was to
set up some sort of dollar cost average
system there are so many apps out there
to help you do that if you're looking
for an app you can check out my website
theminoritymindset.com we have a ton of
different recommendations based off your
goals
and all you do now is set up a system
like for me it's Wednesdays where money
is pulled out of a checking account and
then it's automatically invested into
things like ETFs which is an exchange
traded fund these are things that give
you exposure to a number of different
companies so now instead of investing in
one company for example McDonald's and
hoping that the McDonald's corporation
grows because the risk is that
McDonald's was bankrupt and now you lose
everything
you can invest in ETF which gives the
exposure to say 500 different companies
and now you limit the risk you do limit
some of the upside but you limit the
risk you just keep doing this over the
long term whether the market is up or
down and is completely passive it's
automatic and you want to keep this
consistent no matter what's happening in
the markets and you just do this month
after month year after year and over
time you'll see wow my portfolio is
really growing and this is happening on
autopilot that's how real wealth is
built yeah yeah what about crypto
crypto is fun I like crypto I know
nothing about crypto all I know is that
there are a lot of people that love it
and when they love it they're really
passionate about it and I asked my
financial advisor a long time ago I was
like hey what about crypto
and he was like you know we spent
a hundred hours between us and the
company or like each trying to figure
out why we should invest in this and why
money should go there and he said we
couldn't figure out a good reason and
that anybody can start their own
cryptocurrency and so part of me the
skeptic or the conspiracy in me goes
yeah well that's because he works in the
dollar market so like they're protecting
their own Market but then I was like you
know I don't know I also trust him and
so I mean what what's the deal with
crypto what role is that gonna play I
invest my money in five places one is my
own business and startups second is real
estate third is stocks fourth is crypto
fifth is physical gold and it's in this
order where gold is my smallest
investment in my own business startups
are my number one yeah crypto is part of
the risky speculative part of my
portfolio and people got into crypto
originally because of lack of trust for
the dollar where uh you know we talked
about inflation briefly I don't want to
go too deep into that but essentially
our dollars have lost a lot of value
over the last century they're going to
continue to lose value why because our
Central Bank the Federal Reserve Bank
can keep printing money on command and
anytime you print more money without
producing more wealth it devalues the
dollar so crypto was originally supposed
to provide you with a way to move away
from the dollar and move away from the
control of say the government and the
central banks
and
that's was the original like Bitcoin
that was kind of the original premise
for that
and over time it evolved yes you saw the
growth of meme coins a bunch of crap
coins now at the end of the day
cryptocurrency has value for two reasons
its use and its Network
what does that mean well use means what
can this cryptocurrency do because if
you're buying a cryptocurrency because
you want to get rich in 30 days or 60
days you're buying it for the wrong
reasons and sure maybe you'll go up but
eventually that's going to go to zero
like there's no value there
but in terms of use many
cryptocurrencies have something called
blockchain technology but all
cryptocurrencies do but the blockchain
allows you to do many things
within the crypto to build upon the
software because now cryptocurrency the
blockchain is becoming more of a
software than just a currency
that's where there's a lot of value
because now for example I'll give you
this kind of direct examples uh things
like ethereum which is another
cryptocurrency there's a blockchain
which allows you to build things like
smart contracts
and what does a smart contract do it
allows you to build a digital contract
which says You must perform X and if you
perform X you will get y if we don't
perform X you don't get Y and so it is
completely digital and it's completely
automatic that way now you can build
these types of contracts and send out
payments completely automatically that
doesn't have human error so one of the I
guess simplest examples could be
you own a home
and it's rented out for a thousand
dollars a month and the tenants must pay
you a thousand dollars a month by the
first of the month if they don't
then they get locked out of the home
sounds mean but just as an example and
so that can be done through a smart
contract where now a thousand dollars
must be automatically deposited if it
isn't then this thing happens so these
that's what the blockchain can do
provides that use and the second aspect
is the network of people actually using
that blockchain so for example Facebook
is built upon the network effect
Facebook by itself doesn't have any
value Facebook has value because many
people use Facebook if you went on to
your timeline or news feed and nothing
was there you're not going to go back
onto Facebook the more people that use
Facebook the more value that Facebook
has because more people are using it and
so cryptocurrency works the same way in
the network side where if more people
are using a particular cryptocurrency
then it becomes more valuable because it
can be transacted it can be used and it
can be built upon
so that's the two aspects of
cryptocurrency where you have to
understand the use case and then you
have to understand the network aspect
and that's where the value of
cryptocurrency lies and this is where
you know you have to be able to
differentiate yourself from the noise in
crypto which is people saying I'm going
to get rich uh we're just going to
double our money in cryptocurrency we're
going to take over the world versus I
think that there's actual value in the
technology and I want to invest in that
for the long term but also understand
it's going to be a very bumpy ride
you're going to see a lot of volatility
you're going to see big movements up and
down with the horse Finders on yeah and
if you can't if you can't handle that
please don't invest in crypto so what
percentage do you think is a a a safe
amount or what do you recommend so this
is you know it
if you were just starting your net worth
yeah if you're just starting off as an
investor
you don't want to be putting money into
you know just the speculative
Investments like there should be one of
the smallest things in your portfolio
because when you're starting off you
want to build things like cash flow you
want to build have the sustainable
Investments but as you grow now you can
start taking more calculated risks like
it's understanding which part of your
life do you want to take risks because
in the beginning yeah you know sometimes
risk can be more valuable too
but just understanding how much risk are
you comfortable with you know if you're
okay with risk you know 10 20 depending
on
where you are financially if your
cryptocurrency portfolio went to zero
are you going to go homeless or is it
not going to affect you yeah and this is
where you have to understand that aspect
and then make your decisions accordingly
because it is risky it is speculative
um and so for based off of that
how are you going to invest like if I
looked at my a percentage of my
portfolio
cryptocurrency is is less than 10
percent of my entire net worth
I don't even know if it's 10 but it's
it's very small yeah relatively but I
like it it's fun and exciting but I have
my money in it but I also understand it
if I went to zero I'll be okay yeah
maybe that's a good guideline Armani's
not backed by gold anymore right that's
correct okay and that's a problem it
seems like well
it's a problem especially if you don't
understand money so president Richard
Nixon like fully severed are tied to the
gold standard
we used to be backed by physical goals
because well the United States had a lot
of debts that we could not pay off we
were spending way more money than we
were bringing in and this is creating a
lot of concerns because a lot of
countries around the world own dollars
and so when we were spending all this
money without enough wealth to back it
people were getting concerned because if
for example you you earned fifty
thousand dollars a year but you spend
half a million dollars at Gucci in Louis
Vuitton your credit card company is
going to get very concerned and they're
going to start calling you up well
that's kind of what was happening with
the United States where we were spending
way more money than we had coming in and
that we were worth based on gold
and so countries started asking for
their dollars they said okay we we want
our debts paid give us our money back
and and so president Richard Nixon was
running into a very tough situation
where we didn't have that type of money
and we could have potentially defaulted
so instead of doing that what he said
was we're going to sever ties with the
dollar sorry we're going to severtise
with physical gold
and
now we have the ability to essentially
print money on command so you earn 50
Grand a year you spend 500 000 at Gucci
in Louis Vuitton you can't pay it off
credit card company calls you you say
hold on you turn on the money printer
you print half a million dollars and now
you paid off your debts this is a racket
this doesn't make sense this is
well that's that's exactly exactly right
it
comes with consequences
and the consequence is inflation because
now anytime you print more money the
value of each individual dollar goes
down
and
we have a great benefit here at the
United States because we have the
strongest military in the world we have
the strongest economy in the world and
we are the world's preserved currency
everybody in the world wants to own
dollars so this gives us that power and
ability to do things like printing money
now we're not the first civilization or
organization or country or Empire to
print money this has been happening
since the early Roman Empire
and what has happened every single time
is when you start debasing the currency
meaning you start producing more
currency than there is wealth because
you start printing it essentially that
the value of your currency goes down
which can also cause the Empire country
civilization to go down and I mean if
you look at the great Roman Empire the
the old civilization Roman Empire
what do they do they used to transact on
physical silver and then their
government wanted to expand they wanted
to build the infrastructure they wanted
to do more things
and in order to fund that they didn't
necessarily have all the syllabus so
what they started doing was they debased
the silver by mixing cheaper Metals with
the physical silver now it was great in
the short term because now they had more
money to pay out to their contractors
and workers but eventually people said
this new D based coin and silver is not
worth as much as a whole silver coin so
people needed more money causing more
inflation and eventually that was one of
the big drivers to the collapse of the
Roman Empire now in the last modern
history if you look at the last few
hundred years we've seen Rises and Falls
of civilizations Ray dalio is probably
the best educator on this if you want to
learn more he has a book called The
Changing world order I highly recommend
that and what he talks about is if you
look at the last few hundred years we
have gone through Empires such as uh
right now we are the United States is
the world's Empire but if you go back a
little while ago first it was the Dutch
Empire and the Gilder and
what happened was they became the world
currency the world like Empire the
superpower and then they needed to take
care of everything and they started
spending so much money more than they
were bringing in and then they started
printing money and this caused more
inflation and It ultimately led to the
collapse or the the fall of the Dutch
Empire but also gave the rise to the
British Empire and the pound and then
that was the world's Reserve currency
that was the world's Empire and the
pound was what everybody wanted and
London was a place to be
and then after a lot of spending after
World Wars I've heard a lot of issues
that caused the collapse of the British
Empire because of all the inflation that
they had because they started spending
so much money and then that gave rise to
the United States Empire
um and we came to really become the
world's observed currency I believe in
1944 so you're talking about the end of
World War II after Britain spent a lot
of money on these world wars and so it
gave us the ability now to come to rise
United States became the Royal Empire
and now we're spending a lot of money to
take care of countries around the world
to take care of our own people to do a
lot of things we're spending a lot more
than we're bringing in that's why we
have a 31 trillion dollar national debt
now this is okay when you are on top
everybody wants the dollar everybody you
know is trying to keep you in their good
favor because you're on top
but then that of inflation eventually
starts to catch up no matter I mean this
has happened across civilizations
and once that inflation starts to catch
up now countries around the world try to
take your place and they
will you know do whatever they can to do
that and this is where there are things
that you can do to extend your lifespan
like how there are things you can do as
a human to live longer eat healthier
exercise do things they're not always
the funnest but there are things that
you can do to help your body stay longer
there are things that you can do as a
country or Empire or civilization to
stay on top longer but it's painful that
would be things like cutting spending as
a government it'd be things like like
paying down a national debt that way we
can reduce inflation do some things that
will
help the value of the dollar long term
but it's a price that we have to pay
today because when you cut spending
people don't like that yeah that's
cutting welfare cutting Social Security
nobody wants to see the social security
check get cut
but this is where we have to decide you
know what do we want to do and how are
we going to pay off our national debt
how are we going to reduce our deficit
how can we bring down inflation without
creating an uproar and while keeping
unity and Harmony within a country and
its people and so you know it's the very
complex topic when you talk about you
know are we backed by gold no and this
is where things do get a little
concerning now again I don't say this
you don't want to be panicking it's just
understanding the situation so you can
make better decisions with their money
but recently you've seen the brics
countries which are Brazil Russia India
China and South Africa come together
talking about how they want to create
their own new Reserve currency I think
it originally started the Russian China
coming together
and they wanted to build a new currency
uh away from the dollar
that they wanted to be backed by Metals
things like physical gold and so over
the years Russia has been working the
stockpile physical gold maybe it's
because of that but these are kind of
just things that are happening where you
know history while it doesn't repeat
itself it does rhyme and it's very
beneficial to pay attention to what's
happened in the past that way you can
understand okay this is what's going to
happen
what does this mean for you now it's
more reason for you to be financially
educated and to invest your money and
not just save all of your cash
because you know there's this it's just
the reality what's happening like this
is it's not anything to be scared about
it's just this is the world that we're
in this is how the economy works we go
through crashes we go through recessions
this has happened forever every eight to
12 years we see some sort of Market slow
down Mark some sort of economic slowdown
yet every time we see a recession or a
market crash people get so blindsided
they're so scared they get so hit off
guard because we never expect it to
happen but it always has happened in
fact before the 2020 pandemic
we were in the longest bull market the
longest economic growth period in the
history of modern America
in the last hundred years
and so it was it was you know one of
those things where it is you're right I
mean it's
you know unfortunate or fortunate it
this is just economics now right and so
this is one of those things of
instead of being always upset about the
system understand it being educated
about it that way you can make better
decisions and not be
emotional and panic because no good
financial decisions come out of fear and
no good financial decisions come out of
panic yeah
all right well we'll wrap it up with
what you think maybe is the best and the
worst thing to come from what happened
in the last couple of years with
everything from you know Financial
stimulus I think I heard you say they're
doubling IRS agents so coming after
money now
um to you know supply chain issues to
you know months and months and months if
not really years of losing uh cash flow
in certain sectors but also on the other
side of things when something goes away
another thing comes in and I my belief
of about money is that it's just energy
and so when it goes one if it goes away
from something else it's going toward
another and we saw so many things
blossom and grow that hadn't before
during the during the last couple of
years because of circumstances changing
so there's also great opportunity and
people learning how to monetize without
a brick and mortar and so like what are
the best and worst things you think
um are are to come from the last couple
of years in the pandemic I love the way
that you put that that's a great way to
put it and you're right you know we
every time we hear the word recession we
assume only bad but the reality is a lot
of good comes out of recessions like
more millionaires are majoring
recessions than any other time but you
have to be educated about it and you
know some of our most popular companies
today things like uber Airbnb Microsoft
Apple all of these were started during
recessions so it's one of those things
where understanding the opportunity now
like you said I think one of the the
greatest things for people is just the
changing in our Workforce like it's kind
of funny I mean personally here before
the pandemic our team was in the office
every single day it was just like one of
those things you know we're Innovative
we're creative but we were still here
every day now it's a completely hybrid
work culture where uh you can we come to
the office one day a week if you're not
in town that's okay table we do a one
day a week team day
and it's much more flexible and it's
crazy it took a pandemic to change our
work environment but
it just kind of is what it is so I think
that's one of the great things the
second thing is I think a lot of people
became more interested in financial
education because when the 2020 market
crash happened we saw this huge boom of
people wanting to start investing their
money or trading their money now I don't
recommend trading I'm a much more
advocate for investing but it got people
interested which I think is great and
third I think the movement towards
digital
education has been very good not just
because I'm on YouTube and I'm online
but I think people realizing that hey I
can learn different things on the
internet because
you had people paying 20 to 60 000 a
year
for their college degree now watching
their classes from their bedroom like on
a webinar versus
you're realizing oh my God I can watch
the same thing learn the same stuff from
YouTube for free why am I paying 100
Grand to get a degree to do that and so
it's not like it's bad to get a college
degree but really understanding the cost
benefit of it and when is the right
situation for you to go to college when
does the right for you to borrow a
certain amount of money it's just being
more educated more well aware of your
options which I think is great so I
think those are some of the best things
that happen for the pandemic
now in terms of the cons like you said I
think we did over stimulate and we're
paying the price for that through
inflation and I don't think that this
has gone away yet I think that inflation
is going to be around I think our
economy is going to continue to slow
down and people are becoming much more
aware and educated about the way that
our economy works but the Federal
Reserve Bank does what stimulus does I
think we're still very uneducated but
much more educated today than we were
three years ago
so I think those are the things where
you know we're seeing a lot of positive
um but we're going to see the the
financial and economic pain and the
consequences over the next decade
because of everything that we did over
the last few years I like to look at the
positive so I I'm glad you mentioned
three of those because I think that's
really where it's going I think it takes
takes a burning down for like Alchemy to
happen in the Phoenix to rise and
something new okay final final question
this is just like a fun one yeah
um if you if you had five thousand
dollars someone has five grand and
they're like I want to invest five grand
somewhere somehow what what would you
recommend they do
okay assuming that you only have five
thousand dollars I would invest this
money into yourself because if you
invest this money into the stock market
maybe you'll get a seven to ten percent
return which is fine
but I would say take that money invest
it in yourself build on your education
take a class read a bunch of books start
with that instead of throwing all of it
into a class and then invest somewhere
into your own idea because that
experience that you get is invaluable
and if you can build something with that
five thousand dollar investment can turn
into 50 million dollars there's no limit
to what you can grow with two and uh
there's the best investment as you
especially if you're just getting
started
perfect I love it thank you so much wow
I had so much fun having a conversation
about money for the first time and you
had such a good job of making things
simple which I need thank you well you
asked great questions very intellectual
questions so I appreciate the
opportunity
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button